weißt du ich glaube es in russell wird
der waffel gesagt okay leute wir waren
alle morgens in unserem bett auf und wir
denken deutschland ist ein sicherer ort
immer falsch und der beweis ist jetzt in
den youtube trends platz eins die texte
und zwar ist platz 1 in den youtube
trends in deutschland gerade ich habe
eine waffe im see gefunden solch der
polizei seien solche polizei von zehn
besten wenn man sich dieses video summe
anschaut
hast du da irgendwelche hintergedanken
was eventuell damit sein könnte ich
glaube das ist echt und also jetzt
wirklich eine waffe gefunden weil wie
viele menschen finden jeden tag in
deutschland waffen jungen stellen
100.000 sind ja heute morgen zu dir
gefallen ich habe auf dem weg halt ohne
wird drei sturmgewehre gefunden aus dem
auto die lage an dem dmk ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen wollte ich habe so eine
ahnung dass irgendwas in diesem video
nicht stimmen könnte dass wir schon mal
eine waffe alter nie im leben
diese wird millionär muss ich da haben
wir nun zu 5000 frage ich habe angst sie
verbinden diese antwort a
ich gehe zur polizei anfang machen
youtube-video darüber weiß nicht was
polizei ich sagte ihnen einfach dass ich
aus wieder angefasst haben
jetzt lassen wir gehen nicht mehr ich
hoffe ich hoffe dich das ist jobs ich
hab es wieder nicht ganz gesehen ich
hoffe es ist ein job und er sagt am ende
soll
leute ich habe mich erwischt darauf
reingefallen das war natürlich völlig
alte aber was das für eine video länge
eigentlich 19 minuten lang nach krass
ich habe mich was der macht die ganze
zeit kann ich keine waffen finden körper
deutschland dienstag
irgendwo da drin ist was irgendwann
irgendwo da drin ist ein
vollautomatisches maschine gehört das
finden wir schon da habe ich mich ein
bisschen gefragt so was gibt es denn
noch drin weil ich weiß gibt es so viele
sachen von denen niemand erwarten würde
was sowieso da kommt ja zum beispiel
schusswaffen natürlich dann das kölner
stadtarchiv das ist ja und ja ich glaube
ich habe letztens da so ein asiatisches
land mit 20 millionen einwohnern gesehen
in der als darin werde ich heute mich
auf die suche begeben denn ich habe ihm
entfernt gesehen wie leute in so ein
wasser im sohn sehen wie es hier zum
beispiel eingang sind die ohren gefunden
haben so geld gefunden ich glaube sein
wäre etwas ganz anderes gefunden hat sei
es entweder das hier gefunden so was hat
er wahrscheinlich auch gefunden
das ja sogar pistole also wenn jetzt
ganz misstrauisch werden und zusätzlich
malerei
dann würde man jetzt vielleicht denken
okay sein das wird gesehen diese art von
videos interessiert viele leute ich
glaube ich gehe mal bei mir in hamburg
vor die tür und finde ein paar
gegenstände aber das kann ich nicht
sagen wir das nicht machen
zunächst wird das ist ein schalter aber
wir werden hoffentlich heute ein paar
geile sache sieht ja wie das wasser so
ran kommt ne ist so ein bisschen wie
nennt man das blut apple das muss der
grund sein
das wasser kommt dran so flut tsunami
das ist das da hinten die
freiheitsstatue im wasser
doch ja ohne schalter kreis muss auch
mal sagen eigentlich respekt an seinem
des jona also wie wir sie nicht zum
helden der ist halt schon so lange dabei
und schafft's 2018 immer noch auf platz
1 zu kommen ist schon schwer zu springen
und du was sagen ich bin doch
vorgeführte hashtags lustige kommentare
schreiben die kommentare
kann man es jetzt so weitergeht ich habe
schon mal anstatt auf jeden fall ein
stock ist jetzt glaube ich nicht so viel
wert wie kann also was ist mit dir mal
haben in steinach da haben wir auch ein
paar sauerstoffmangel im wasser gefunden
die sind glaube ich jetzt nicht so viele
leute seien in wahrheit ist unterwegs
aber so richtig so oft fake ich hab was
gefunden ich habe glaube ich etwas
gefunden waren wir vielleicht etwas gott
ich muss etwas richtig cooles neues
denken hier
ich glaube hier wurden baby kommt über
diese welt der musik also wir sind dabei
minute 37 16 minuten stand es gibt mal
vorzunehmen spannenden partner kann halt
so passieren
ich habe mich in dem tesa streifen
verändert bisher auf jeden fall gespannt
haben noch nicht wirklich viel gefunden
erwartet haben
die haben gesagt das ist das gute essen
oder so der irgendwie so ein
das glaube ich eine rolex nein niemals
nein denn die karten schauen wir wissen
es aber noch nicht hatte aber noch gar
nicht was er dazu fähig befunden
tatsächlich wieder im kommen wir sofort
ja okay weil ich wirklich glaube ist ein
hoffen mit der waffe gesagt weißt du ich
glaube dafür dass die waffel klingt das
würde ich dich anfassen
hast du schon folgen du hörst also das
plastik ist ne ich habe so viel schnee
liegt achten auf das geräusch wenn
er/sie hinlegt weil ich so die
glaubhafte achtung ist gleich ich
schwöre ich aus eisen und man auf leute
wenn es gab mal das fand man heraus
gezogen von dem video hier schauen wir
ein suchen die qualität seiner scheiße
ich habe keine ahnung von waffen ehrlich
gesagt nicht wirklich also fürs oft erst
habe ich früher schon mega interessiert
jetzt nicht mehr
das sieht ausweis nicht walther p99 was
mal gucken wie das weiter logo aussieht
weiß nicht ob bist du zuerst schauen wir
dass das walter logo könnte schon sein
mit seinem 8 94 vergleich das war ja das
ist also das soll es sein das ist aber
ein steckschuss prima dass sie sogar in
schwarz das ist genau die doch bestimmt
ne vergleiches mal das ist genau die
walther p99 klickt man auf den link bei
amazon wird aber nicht wert ist kein
echtes ein du kannst du mich verarschen
hey warum sind da oben rechts software
kugeln pro woche kostet 249 vor günstige
alter weiß was das geistes wäre wenn er
untergeht wird auch zusammengekauft und
also bist du eine und schnell
er war also ich will keine
verschwörungstheorie freuen aber ich
würde sagen dass es die waffe seines
videos ich denke ich zeige meine hände
drauf der fingerabdrücke er ganz kurz
ich muss kurz demonstrieren ich bin so
verbrecher der sondern mit einer waffe
einzogen waren ab hier ist so der sehne
dann umgebracht und damals sowie den
sportunterricht nicht mehr so muss man
sie direkt auf dem boden an lehrern und
dann halt dass es direkt in den bus
steigen und halt nicht springen
jetzt ist ja dafür dass zwei flügen
verlassen würden die gerichte richtig so
als ob das gerade recht ist das ist ja
so krass gesagt habe ich aber das kann
ja nicht ernst meint er löst es irgendwo
auf muss ja
der löst ist auch im video doch auch das
ist was es sein kann
wir sind ein bisschen unter schock das
ding ist du siehst du hier diese häuser
sind so reichen gegen so häuser hier
blabla
ich glaube wir hatten vor keiner ein
paar wochen so ein überfall ihrem haus
richtig mit gefährlichen raubüberfall
waffen und so vielleicht sind die er
vielleicht sind die räuber haben
überfall gemacht mit sind die längst
haben das ding hier eingeschmissen die
hätten halt inserate können wo es runter
geht uns niemand
wir bespielen falls sie noch mal
wiederkommen müssen weil anders die
kehrseite auch noch in dieser gegend
also die sind nicht einfach die leute
eine waffe haben dass da noch mehr
wir haben aber wir haben hier da haben
wir doch ein 74 da drin
das schafft die grenze ganz kurz jahre
liegt da liegt eine potenzielle
mordwaffe aber dass sie gar etwas
verwirrt sie gerettet
vielleicht hat jemand auch wie hier
geraucht genommen vom überfall durch die
hat es in der erklärung
aus den letztens war ich glaube das ist
für mich richtig krass okay auf jeden
fall gut fürs video hoch
ich bin ich sicher ich glaube ich dass
diese story wohl hier ein raubüberfall
war schon echt vier nummern zu viel
würd sagen wir gehen damit zur
monatsbericht ich würde sagen wir gehen
damit zur polizei
mit diesem start ist durch die haben wir
ja immer da und bringt auf die
polizeiwache
ich wollte es nicht einfach nur den
starken staat da ist nicht viel wert
glaubt sagen wir gehen das problem dass
erst einmal mit nie zur polizei bringen
ich habe einen traum mit dir ist nämlich
schon dreimal in der hand
also es ist garantiert fake 1000% wenn
es wenn denn eine echte waffe gefunden
hat dann hat mir meine rechte hand ab
heute kein denkt ich würde sagen eine
ganz gute stelle für eine sinnvolle
botschaft noch mal wenn ihr auf eurem
schulweg oder auf dem weg in die uni
schusswaffen auf der straße findet was
ja auch vorkommt in deutschland wie wir
alle wissen dann fast die erste drei bis
viermal an macht oder fingerabdrücke
drauf dann im stock und dann mit dem
handtuch einpacken und zur polizei bonn
und veröffentlicht auf ihn zu wenn alles
gut